hey good morning everybody
um good morning
uh we're we I don't think we'll wait to
start for our
um
we're each mission one person no I know
Senator Lang is here
will be along very shortly I've asked
representative Dolan is will not be here
but I've asked for a replacement I
haven't been notified that there will be
one so we'll do what we can
Okay so
looking at this convenient side by side
um
there's
looks like it's absolutely the same as
um
as the house version representative
Broder thank you I had a question in the
Senate version the reference to RSA 310a
let me just make sure what page are you
on I'm on page 12.
so the
RSA 310a colon 1-e was removed from the
Senate version
and that was in the house version which
is where we I thought put the
uh that's because House Bill 655 deleted
RSA 310a1
okay so all right what version are you
looking at we're looking at the side by
side prepared by our researcher right
but I set you on page 12. I'm on page 12
of a side by side page 11 is side by
side all of the side by side sorry
excuse me gotcha I was looking in the
bill my apology that's okay you have the
side by side
yeah
I have an extra copy
and yes can I I'd like to
um
also
in in these house version I mean the
Senate version I'm sorry you added a um
paragraph had to do with exemptions for
Physicians licensing license out of
state was that an amendment that I I
think the house saw that Amendment but
did we add it to another bill I thought
we added it to another that language I
believe is in
409 or something similar this is the
this is in the Physicians and surgeons
scope of practice
and we we had something under Telehealth
um
I just want to make sure that we're not
so the language I'm just trying to get
to where you are that was paged side by
side page 13. section
um eight of the Senate version of the
bill yep
so that language was language that
Senator Rosenwald had put in and we
originally heard it as an amendment to
409 but we moved it into 532.
so it that language is not informal even
though it was introduced in the uh
actually was it was important yeah I
think we did it as a number I think we
we put it into a Senate bill that's
right we added it to a Senate bill which
is why I'm we don't want to duplicate
efforts
so we we moved a few things around there
at the end and no
I'm not
I don't did you you added this language
into a Senate bill I believe it was two
I'm looking at uh 207 yeah
I might have 207 here I do but I thought
207 was mostly their their Appeals it
had a lot of other odds in them too okay
it's either 207 or one or so
uh looks like 107. I'll just say I think
it might be 107. okay
107.
I do not have 107 with me here
just a moment I'm looking it up
listen
as part of that whole amendment that uh
and then we separated
so I think it is yeah
no it's not in 107 because
I wrote the amendment for 107.
and that Amendment came the same day
that we were discussing House Bill 105
so we didn't put it into 107. okay
all right I mean I'm starting this is
all starting because we've seen this so
many times I can't remember where it
ended up it's yeah
except that
someplace we put it in
relative to telemedicine
rather than the Physicians
was it the bill that had to do with the
Department of Corrections that was a
different experience it was a different
exemption okay
let's see where
this section
yes
126.
okay okay Senator Bill 120s
and 26. ah licensure for Telehealth
I don't think so that's just that's the
corrections one
so maybe it just didn't I don't it
didn't get added
apparently not we considered it half a
dozen times we've seen this many times
and I can't remember I don't remember
I didn't write an amendment and I know
for Edna in the house to add it to
anything but I just and I I guess I'm
thinking that because you originally
going to put it in 409 that that's where
it was and I didn't want it to be in two
different places but you did not include
this in 409 and you throw nine I think
at the last minute we took it out of
four nine and put it in 532. I know we
put together a non-germaine amendment
that had a lot of stuff in it and we
just tagged it to 409 and then we
parched things out and separated them
accordingly
so that may be the confusion
well we saw it several times okay
um and I know you had a different way
you wanted to structure it but I just
don't know if we saw that language well
we wanted
at some point we had a revision to the
Telehealth statute itself that said
uh that
you could continue a relationship yes
I'm pretty sure that was in the house
let's look at the amendment to House
Bill six
the Second Amendment to House Bill 655
oh no that's what we attached to Senate
Bill 409 right right right right so it's
not in there
well I'll just check the last version I
have
could I ask
um Mr ostern how the this question
because I believe okay
I believe I asked him this question I
just wanted to make sure were you able
to check that
so what we're looking at is the side by
side by 532 and um the last page 13
Section 8 which is a new paragraph from
the Senate Amendment
yeah that's side by side the last page
11 I mean 13. that's really the only I
just we just want to make sure that we
didn't stick this someplace else and
then we're going to duplicate
things that could possibly conflict
it would have been if we put it it would
have been in a Senate bill
yes and we would have put I thought I
thought the I'm almost positive that all
the components of House Bill 655 that
were the leftovers
and anything that we want to add to oplc
was added as an amendment to 409.
from our side
so if it wasn't a time no no Senate Bill
409 sorry Senate Bill 409 so if it's not
in there there isn't a Senate bill for
it in its House Bill 409
so that would have been
with us that we've done
them right
and that would have been 107 or
um
were the two bills that we sent over and
I don't see it in either of them I'm
quite certain that this language
originated in the Senate from Senator
Rosenwald you're correct it did yes it
did and we heard about it when we were
dealing with Senate bills so if we
passed it it would have been in the
Senate bill
okay we you know we went over this
amendment to 409 a detailing committee
and it didn't have
yeah we separated this language out we
put it into 532 out of 409 right
do you have an answer to that well
that's the way I recall it too because I
think when Senator Rosenwald introduced
this as Senate Edna it wasn't a
different bill but the language just got
picked up and shifted around when 409
and 532 were sort of being tweaked at
the end but I don't think
at least I haven't seen it up here in a
separate place so I think this is the
only place my recollection is she
originally came in with the language of
wanted it in 655. yes and I didn't want
to make a amendment to 655 where I
pushed it all into 409 and 532. that's
how I remember it too and then the other
fixes to telemedicine we just did by
adding like RSA 328d and you know like
we just added statute references so that
we didn't have any other language on
telemedicine
foreign
well as long as it's not a duplicate
and it seems as though it is it is not a
duplicate then that's okay okay
great
were there any other changes to the
music therapist part
ly I thought we added a position for
oplc
that was in the fiscal note to um it was
actually in the house bill
yeah but I thought we changed it
no one it's if you look on the side by
side page 12 one program Assistant two
position labor grade 15. there was a
position in HP 30 37 that was added
after I testified
that Wednesday morning okay so maybe
I've got the two mixed up in my head I
was thinking it was this bill that we
added one to that one is attached to
house bill 337. yeah right the attorney
too he's right okay this one's this
one's a looks like a licensing Clerk
different position they were entire
places I guess I was we had too many
bills and I'm remembering the wrong
thing I had a lot of oplc yes well yes
that's why we uh put the
OLS can reconcile the uh yes the
references because that's that's
definitely a concern
okay uh so since we can't find the
language the Telehealth language
anywhere else yep it's I I can't object
to it
do you want a motion do we need to
motion or do we just have to agree
um
be a thermal or informal as you as you
like
all right I'm in agreement with the
with the Senate
I agree also okay any uh you're in
agreements
okay
I will write a report saying so and uh
all right great thank you
we appreciate you coming along with us
understand what exactly you're doing
all right so we are we in an adjournment
on this committee
all right 5 32 years old thank you
all right
good morning everyone
um good morning good morning
House Bill 409 was
the house version is completely gone
so
we'd like you to
like the Senate to convince us that we
should adopt your version
right now because it's really good
thank you Senator that's an excellent
start there are some sections we'd like
a bit more detail on so um House Bill
409 came about we used it as a vehicle
for all of the changes that we found
necessary to house bill
uh
six fifty five and 594 if we had any
change so we wanted to pass those two
clean as they came over from the house
so that they could just go right through
and then we used uh 409 and the last one
that we just did on the music therapy is
sort of two vehicles for putting the
changes that we found we needed out of
the committee so um there are a lot of
changes I guess it might be easier to go
just to the points that you have some
some issues with rather than going
through the whole bill if that makes
sense right
um unless somebody has a concern about
the
uh temper conditional definition of a
regulated social worker which I
okay the temporary license for medical
imaging
no problem the Board of Nursing we want
to
have
two advanced practice registered nurses
instead of one
that's at the top of page one of the
bill which the version we have isn't
numbered but it's there
and we want to delete the change to the
following paragraph
that has a
nurse member of the board specifically
representing nursing education
because we feel that's a conflict of
interest
I need to get to the right copy of the
bill here that we're on would you like
our copy of our side by side is that
this one here
yes okay are you referring to that or
the bill itself I'm
the bill itself is included in the back
of that package oh okay I got you I
didn't I didn't scroll back far enough
what's Beijing all right
yeah you're right there's no numbers no
back one
okay at the top of the right hand page
okay gotcha okay
uh
2A prns
instead of one so they are in here
if that's agreeable
it's a big board but there are something
like 30 000 nurses and that board has
not had any trouble getting a quorum
um
they're in favor of going to 13 people
and we since they don't have a problem
like I don't see any objection to that
so that bill is one that board is when
you'd send it over at 12 to us and I
added a 13th member because I don't like
even numbered boards and so we have
that's a reasonable position yeah so we
added a an LNA to that and what you're
proposing is to remove the
um
the nursing education requirement and
change that to an APR am I correct um
yes the simplest way to do that is to
change
it says on the top line of that page six
registered nurses two of whom shall be
in APRN
okay and then delete the new language at
the bottom of the next paragraph
Senator thank you
thank you madam chair
um that language concerning nursing
education is language that I had brought
in there was a group of nurses and I
can't remember what their title are of
Southern New Hampshire Nurses
Association they had been looking at the
activities of the board and one of the
things that they had requested was that
we have one nurse dedicated just for
nursing education and so that's why
Vince is put in there and they had
recommended that they had the minimum of
a master's degree or health related
field at least five years of educational
experience
um it's my understanding and I think we
had had it during testimony that they do
have one nurse who works with education
on the board but that is not her sole
purpose and or her
um the position it's not a dedicated
position and so what they were hoping to
get would be somebody from a nursing
education program
um to be on the board
representative
Mike and our concerned with that is that
that person could be biased towards
their program and it's not a
um
would have conflict of interest so
that's why we don't want someone with
associated with nursing program on the
board
from our hearing where the conflicts
made a little more sense to me which I'm
happy to share but basically this board
of nursing they they certify the
educational programs and so they act in
sort of a regulatory capacity to these
institutions and so that could
create a conflict of interest but in
addition during that process there's
non-public information that's shared
about some of the education programs and
so competitors could have access to some
of that non-public information so when I
listened to it again it just it made
sense to me that perhaps putting this
this education person on the board had
some unintended consequences so I just I
want to share that with you yeah that
helps we the there's a new paragraph
allowing the board to establish
subcommittees in particular an education
subcommittee that would focus on the the
approvals
and I think that's a better way to
handle it than to have a member from a
training education program on the board
specifically as such okay there's
there's no you know there's no
restriction on how the other nurses are
chosen
and across on how do you feel about that
change
the the only thing is you know I and it
does say in here
um a practice and education committee so
hopefully the Board of Nursing will
establish an education subcommittee and
they the individuals that will be on it
will be able to do the job
um the this organization was just really
really concerned about
um
education of nurses and making sure
everything is up to date and
um
so I'm
I'm okay with it okay I think as long as
as they get there I think that will be
fine
okay all right so it sounds like we'll
accept your change of making that two so
what in the very top line you're
proposing to put instead of one of whom
she'll be an advanced it'd be two of who
I guess I don't know if that's
grammatically correct two of them is
okay okay and then there'll be advanced
practice and then we'd be uh deleting
the new language in section two yes that
yeah okay all right does anyone have any
other comments on the the
lights to the rest of the oplc section
um we had received an email and I'm not
sure if
um you folks said also concerning
um some changes with the board of
Optometry
okay Optometry I have not received that
either okay if you continue that it I
didn't see it if I did this is about the
continuing education and this section
deletes the requirement that the
continuing education be reported
annually correct um the email and I'm
showing it to my colleagues
um
uh let's see oh this was way back and
we're happy with deleting that
requirement I don't think we fixed it so
we fixed this okay
my apologies I thought you were looking
at something new in committee yes we did
address that okay I thought so that this
is not part of the changes of 409 or
it's already in it's already been
changed and we're talking about
paragraph seven right Optometry yes yes
we've accepted the word annually it's in
paragraph seven actually Senator okay
yep I'm sorry okay good
all right anything
so further concerns that the house had
with the well can we talk about number
five barbering
because originally 409 was about
barbering
right right
so I just want to make sure that
actually this is similar to what's
what's in hospital
654 which we retained our committee
retained that bill right this doesn't
do most of what 644 does it simply
by Crossing out a sub paragraph B
it deletes the booth license
which is a request of the Board of
Cosmetology
and didn't we do that in hospital too
no no we didn't do it okay so this is
strictly to do with Booth licenses right
okay I'm out that's fine yeah please
um my understanding representative is
that we kept your language but we did
delete in our committee Amendment the
original language of 409. concerning
barbering so we kept I'm sorry can you
repeat that we kept the house
language the amendment that we wrote to
which is what you originally got
my confused matters I'll just State
clearly what I am sure of which is that
um in our committee Amendment we did
delete the original text of
409 yes 409 was originally only about
reciprocity of licenses and 594 covers
that more broadly okay all right okay
great thank you I'm fine yep okay so
we're good
all right this is
okay
foreign
the uh
the
the professional licensor and
certification fund is revised in Senate
Bill 49 I believe but that is set to
take effect after this bill I think
let's check the I'd have to look at that
we need to make sure that it is in fact
after that this so that it overwrites it
okay what are we on which page of the
document are we on
three ten five is that correct two
six eight ten I think
it's uh middle of the left-hand page
it's the funding section
310 colon five Roman two yep
separate
wrap some stores to help we know the
answer to that off the top of his head
[Music]
is and is the 5 million dollars the same
no it's that I yeah I hear it five I
thought it had been taken down to three
right uh that's what Senate Bill 49 does
okay
Senate Bill 49 is effective on passage
Okay so
um if we need to we want to make sure
that this
um
this shall take effects July 1st
so we need to make sure that the
governor has assigned 49 until after he
signs this one yes
can we just change it if it's to match
the numbers instead of yeah
that would be simpler let's just make
sure we do that so we don't you know
depending on somebody to sign something
sometime is representative I think Mr
also helped me have a comedy is to make
you
yes sir I've been working with LBA on
this one and I I think because of the
way 655 and 409 with the July 1
effective date
um they draw that number from June 30th
so if 49 doesn't get signed before June
30th oplc will lapse all the funds
kind of nullifying both of them so the
way they're explaining it to me now is
that and we've this is kind of a
complicated issue when we've been
working with them on it so 655 creates
the July 1 for the 5 million 49 would
effective upon signing our passage
um
would be to delete
that paragraph from 409 so that it
doesn't overwrite Senate bill 49.
is that correct I don't know because 655
still has the July 1 effective date and
they're saying that is the piece that
would supersede 49 in that case
well we can't change Senate Bill 49
because it's concurred we can however
encourage someone to delay it
foreign
I suppose you could do a later effective
date on this so that you have 49 go into
effect on passage July 1 655 language
comes up and then here July 2nd
you could replace
six out of 549 we don't want this
language to overwrite right Senate
before could you make this language
match the language of 49. right right
and if you made it effective July 2nd
that would put the language of 49 back
in control so you'd have 49 for a week
you'd have 655 for a day and then you'd
have the language of 49 now in 409
control again okay so so we need to make
paragraph two match sp49 right which is
three million correct right that's why I
brought it up okay actually it's the two
sub paragraphs
um Roman one and Roman two Roman one and
two yeah there's a
oh because of the 125 percent right
and um no the paragraph Roman 1 says
that the close of the biennium any funds
in excess shall be used to reducing
licensing fees
we may have to confer with OLS on that
and figure out exactly what needs to be
changed but but our intent is that that
this language
of uh sp49 are you okay with that yeah
no no we need to do that yeah
conflict right
yes I made a note
but yes we will we'll change this
language to agree with Senate Bill 49
change the effective date so it was
after July 1st and then
okay yeah Madam chair I think um
if
maybe have the the effective date the
15th of July
because then that way you're going to
have time for 49 and 605 to go through
and this would probably be the last one
it takes a couple of weeks to go through
enrolled bills and then get everybody to
sign off because sometimes people once
the 30th of June comes along everybody
scatters or everyone goes on vacation or
they have plans so perhaps a more
effective date would be the 15th now
would you I'm sure it will take a while
for everything Shake through anyway
that's fine okay okay
all right that's
any other
concerns
and this has got the
um
discipline investigation requirements
that we
agreed to
um
Auto references all right
so does anyone have any any other issues
up to up to section 27.
uh I just put that in Section 8 with the
licenses and renewal labs
yeah section 310 colon 8 license
renewals
I just want to make sure that
we're saying the same thing the language
of the Senate is slightly different than
ours where's what where is this uh
okay
um
section 3108 license renewals
and
yes speak to that
initially
um thanks for the question
representative so
what we were trying to address and we
tried a variety of of different language
approaches is that
um apprentices can have a different
license term and that
um as we standardize oplc license terms
to two years
it's just not reflected in every license
just yet and so we originally said
two years from the date of issuance
because oplc needed a date so they
needed the two years or if different the
terms stated on the face of the license
um
and so I think that raised a couple
concerns
both from oblc and I think from the
electricians and so what we ended up
with was something we sort of drafted
live in committee which is to say except
for those apprentices licensed for one
year in accordance with the rules
adopted in 541a and that was to capture
like
current state in terms of licenses that
were shorter than two years and then
hopefully future State under the rules
adopted if I if I remember yeah okay
that's fine I just wanted to make sure
we understood that thank you
any other concerns
okay
all right section 27 is the Social Work
compact
and
I'm we don't have section numbers on our
yeah draft here so we're it'll work well
so we're trying to find this it's the
last uh
six ten Pages whatever
it doesn't work okay
it says a new section Social Work
compact adopted
there's about 10 pages of it yes
randomly section Pages yeah put
something in here okay
all right
yep reference change positions yeah all
of a sudden we do have section numbers
but some of them do some don't all right
it's a brand new section yes
um
we have
that language in Edna
with a retained bill that and we plan to
to consider it over the over the fall
and probably release it to the house in
January
uh I'm not convinced we need to
short-circuit that process by Plumbing
it into this bill
so the language came to all of us
obviously from oplc and as in my
conversations with the director she was
very uh I don't I don't think Lindsay's
not here today right no she doesn't yeah
she was
very eager to have this in because they
wanted to be in the first seven one of
the first seven states because that that
passes it because that gives us a seat
at the tooth table for rule making going
forward and Doug Mr oselle please feel
free to jump in if I'm not representing
this correctly but and um so that's the
conversation that I had with her and I
took it you know we discussed it in the
senate in committee and we had uh strong
support for adding this language too so
we felt that it was good for us to get
in now we understand and respect that
the house was looking at holding it and
but with this compact language as you
know we have to kind of pass it as it is
or not pass it at all so there isn't
really room to modify or edit we just
felt we were ready to pass it so we put
it in the spill okay thank you uh
Mr osterhaus do you know if how many
states have adopted this language
because I as I recall this is brand new
as of
May
it is brand new and I'm just going off
memory but it may be one or two
maybe two I think but I'd have to
confirm that
my understanding was I'm not certain if
any have yet and it may be one or two
but that many were considering it in the
next in the coming months and that if we
got in on the front end now we would be
on the early end doing that
thank you I have been um speaking with
um
uh director Courtney on this because
oftentimes we see these bills and you
really wonder what the heck has happened
to them after you sign them I mean do we
actually become do the compacts actually
occur and the information that I
received from her which I shared with
the Edna committee was that historically
New Hampshire did this has participated
in these compacts has been a has been
often a member and we are using them so
that during covid I know that the nurses
um we used I think it was did we we our
nursing staff increased by 25
so we do have the ability to use these
compacts to our benefit when needed
and with the this one is this one came
about because of a commission a
committee that Senator Perkins coca and
I and representative McMahon and
representatives Bishop Pirro were at
over the summer to address the hurdles
for mental health workers and this was
cited as a the social worker hurdle is
difficult for us to us or Mount so this
was where this bill came about
and I actually presented a committee I
actually tried to it was House Bill 428
that this social compact was originally
brought to Edna and um I we were going I
was going to ask Edna to attach it to a
Senate bill but indeed you had attached
it to House Bill 409 so I left Let It Go
thinking that we could work this out
today
so obviously the Senate is in support of
the language that we added I guess
all right I think I'd like to have a
brief caucus
okay
we'll just step into our office
foreign
okay thank you for waiting
representative it might if we might let
Mr hostel just add one thing about your
previous question I think he has info
you'll be interested oh yes thank you uh
John dejoy and came up and spoke to me
during the break and told me one state
had passed it but there are eight states
considering
the compact right now and they are all
still in session
thank you
good to know
um
the the house conferees are agreed that
it's a serious issue but we don't want
to be rushed into it
and since we are considering it
and we plan to have it out of committee
by on a retained Bill rather than a new
bill
so I would hope that um you can agree to
deleting this section and incorporating
it in a different bill
so that the Senate feels very strongly
that this is important that we act
immediately on this
uh we we would like to be on the front
end and in those first seven states to
pass it and with the information that Mr
osterhall gave us we really feel
strongly that this needs to remain and
we need to act on it now
all right and um I think in that case we
ought to recess until tomorrow
and
see what we can do about reaching an
agreement on that you want to take a
recess or just take a break
uh well we're good when would a good
point when would we be able to get
together the late this afternoon so so
my understanding is a recess means we
have to then decomply with the 24-hour
notice if we want to just take a break
and talk later we can do that it I think
that would be our preference I don't
know what everyone else understands
three until two
yeah I have one and two as well
um I have two so uh it can't be before
o'clock if that's four o'clock is that
is four o'clock agreeable
today or would you rather wait till
tomorrow
I'm here every single day so yeah I'm
here every day
I want to be respectful of your time
because I don't know what you guys are I
know I'm here Monday Tuesday Wednesday
so
sure
yes I'm pretty sure
I just I have five tomorrow so I'm gonna
be the yeah okay
okay so four four o'clock unless uh
which we're kind of running all over the
place I have one two three hopefully we
I can do four okay I will schedule us to
resume at four o'clock after a break oh
you know what no no nope I can't because
it's I I can pretty well guarantee you
because it's 6 10 which is certifying
patients of therapeutic cannabis you
don't think you'll be down in an hour no
we're not going to be done in an hour
well Senator if you're okay with us
going on without you I mean the center
position is pretty strong fine we will
resume at 4 pm and I'm available any
earlier yes I just have a short I have a
short one at two that's why I'm asking
if you maybe if you want to go quicker
than 2 30 is that uh no we've got one or
two
I will arrange for that and you will be
notified what room that will continue in
okay thank you
yes before we because it's very it's
simple I just want to make sure that the
last uh section the last section was on
repeal and if it refers to obsolescent
references that you put in had to do
with um
administration of the estate commission
the board of manufacturing the
manufacturing installation board these
all these things this is the Detachment
I believe of the administration
Provisions for oplc
I just want to make sure that this is
just a this is cleanup language correct
if I may share yes this is language that
was inserted by oplc because
um
when we pass 655 as it was and when you
guys had taken the different pieces of
Prior oplc requested that I insert this
okay I just want to make sure that we're
not that's fine that's really the only
issue that remains is the social workers
compound right okay thank you okay we've
got some some language tweaks and a new
effective thing
thank you all we'll see you at three
okay
being one o'clock we'll get started
however people yeah they can that is
okay we'll hold
all right being one o'clock we'll get
started
um
on this committee conference for host
Bill 461.
and
I think as on the house position as we
uh look at this we see that
there have been issues where positions
have been
replaced with from full time to
part-time
and
having seen it occur more than once and
it's
has happened
um we look at it on the house side as it
being unfair to the rest of the
employers and changing a position from
full-time to part-time and that city or
town walking away from the unfunded
liability for that position when they do
and passing it on to all the other
groups that have to pick up that cost
um so what we did here if we look at our
version is we put in a penalty that if
they
are not prohibited from doing that
they're just obligated to pay
that unfunded liability portion going
forward until it's paid off
[Music]
um
I can say that
um and I can look at over at Marty and
say there have been positions that have
been changed from full time to part-time
and we're a city or town has walked away
from that
um and we're just trying to stop this
from the continuation of occurring as a
matter of fairness to all those other
communities
and
oh
let you explain why you've amended it
the way you did it on your side thank
you
so we when we heard this bill we
certainly recognized that it could
happen and it may be happening and
they're I'm sure there are a handful of
examples as we got testimony from from
Marty and others and especially for the
municipalities that
it may be happening and it probably is
at a very small level but what we didn't
understand was the impact of how it was
impacting the retirement system for one
and two how it would impact the
municipalities if we said no you can't
do this or you've got to have this
penalty so that's why we felt that
you know the Senate felt that there was
definitely a potentially an issue there
and it warranted looking at but we
weren't ready to step up to the point of
assigning a penalty and saying this is
where you're going to you know this is
where it's going to go so in uh in
working and talking with the municipal
Association and others we felt that it
was best that we take the position of
let's let's take a look at this let's
study it and see how much of an impact
it really is and then having that
information we could go forward if
necessary if we felt legislation was
then warranted
thank you
um
well we did hear in committee that uh
this was happening it has happened in
the past
and and and as as it was said
on our side opposition of it being fair
um
for somebody for a town to take a
full-time position and Mark it down as
to do away with it and say we'll just
handle that with a part-time visit
they're just playing games
and they're playing games in uh in uh
penalizing the New Hampshire retirement
system because as we all know there's a
huge
deficit that must be made up and it will
be made up and
not in my lifetime but in somebody's
lifetime we'll get rid of that deficit
but until then anyone playing games to
uh so they don't have to pay in
uh for whatever amount of money they
think they're saving uh went against the
fairness that we were looking for
um no no representative property well uh
thank you Senator I I would also like to
bring up when this does occur chances
are
as we've seen in the past the person is
eligible for some retirement benefits if
they hit the age and time limits we
require it so therefore this particular
candidate and working for another
Community will be collecting a pension
which will be drawn down again you know
against the pension system on top of
that going to the community that's not
contributing you know and I don't want
to say that it occurs but is are they
doing it because it is the best
candidate
or is there any type of maybe perhaps
open the door
in the negative sense I'm not saying
that it did occur but in a negative
sense it could open the door for
somebody who was popular or something
like that to just uh cement the system
that we have so the best way to defend
the system is to protect it as it is
right now and follow like the house
recommendation
thank you Mr
chairman there were um some real issues
with this legislation and a lot of
tension
um it seeks to really put a blanket
solution to
um
a variety of different entities that are
very different and that in my opinion is
trouble you've got the tension with
local control is the state now going to
be telling the municipalities about the
hiring and and and how to fill positions
do we do we want to go down that road
secondly you've got the issue of towns
versus counties because the counties as
well are political subdivisions and is
how is this going to affect the counties
um you also have the difference between
a very large municipality like Nashua or
Manchester
um laconian I would even argue
Londonderry because we had testimony
concerning Londonderry versus a small
community
so we wanted we figured we would go to a
study committee to try to resolve those
larger issues we also had testimony from
Mr Carlin from the retirement system
that
um he claims that though a position is
downgraded it's not always due to
avoiding pension debt costs it's that
through municipality analysis these jobs
really do become a part-time job so if a
municipality decides they want to
change from a full-time to a part-time
how involved is the state going to be in
that and I believe that question needs
to be resolved as well and then Mr
Carlin also brought up a couple of other
points that I'd like to mention here
um that really deal with the
administrative purposes
um the bill that the bill has to specify
to the New Hampshire retirement system
what to adopt in order to enforce
against uh these avoiding the potential
the pension debt
how are they going to do that they need
us to tell them how to do that secondly
that there needed to be language added
regarding the mechanical process of the
legislation in providing the employers
that the New Hampshire retirement system
is overseeing and how they are to notify
the New Hampshire Retirement System
so because of that testimony that's why
we really said okay we've got to be
really careful what we do here and we've
got to resolve these issues before this
can go forward and we felt that a study
committee was going to be the best way
to do that
Senator Carson oh sorry
thank you very much Mr chair I think
Senator Carson really encapsulated what
we heard and the way the reason we voted
the way we did
I just look at
for all of us
time
is valuable to all of us and we know the
number of study committees that this
legislature has put forward in the past
and we're trying to reduce that going
forward
because we all serve on a number of them
and get stretched pretty thin as we go
into October when these reports need to
be done
I think our feeling is that
the study committee
well it sounds good isn't all that
necessary because I think the retirement
system
has
the information that we're already
looking for as to the positions that
have been
changed from full-time to part-time
and
the amount of uh
how much that the unfunded liability
loses per year when those
positions are changed from full-time to
part-time
um
so I'm not sure a study committee will
get us any further along than what we
can get right now from
Marty in the system to give us those
numbers
um I I hear your concerns about and this
is the first I think we hear of it
of some of the concerns on the way this
legislation was drafted that wasn't
brought to our attention when we heard
the bill that there were issues and how
they would recoup or do what they needed
to do
um so on that end I mean it's when we
put this together we didn't hear any of
those brought forward
with that being said I will leave it at
that and I think we're pretty firm on
putting a stop to this going forward
from here going forward so that
the unfunded liability isn't passed on
to others in cities and towns with these
changes in position
and going to a study committee I think
we can just Reach Out
as a group and ask for what we want for
information without having to have
meetings and
of those Natures to get that
Senator Pearl thank you respectfully Mr
chair we we asked a lot of questions
that of Mr Carlin and and missac as they
came through as to how these are going
to impact the communities and the
information we were looking for they
didn't have answers to at that time and
some of the things that you were looking
for we didn't get answers to and that's
why we decided that
we couldn't in good conscience go
forward and put forth something that
could definitely be a detriment to the
many of the municipalities in the sense
of putting this fine on for them and and
taking them out of the ability to manage
their employees the way they needed to
we had concerns about school systems as
well whether this would impact them we
weren't sure on that there were just too
many things that we didn't have a real
good clear definition on them always
trying to be respectful of the taxpayers
money as well as end all of our time as
well there were many study committees
that I don't think need to happen but to
me I felt that this was and I'm the one
that introduced the language to move it
to a study committee and I felt that
this certainly you know this condition
if it's occurring at any great amount or
great frequency then it could be
detrimental to the system but we just
didn't know the impact that it was
having or could have and that was what
we were concerned about and I think
before the Senate felt before we were
ready to step forward and penalize towns
for making some choices that were good
for their own Community as far as how
they're managing their time and
resources that we wanted to have some
more information so I I think the Senate
at this point is is not willing to move
off from a study committee and because
we feel that this going to this extent
right now without the information we
needed wouldn't be what we would feel
would be a good responsible move
thank you Mr chairman I think uh just
keep it real short here I I think that
I'm I'm not prepared to a c to another
study committee we've got too many uh we
if we want to dig into this we can but
uh the the solution that I'd be looking
for is something other than an
additional study
thank you uh and my question thank you
Mr chair to the Senate uh
this in essence and I think what I
haven't heard in listening to you know
my Senate colleagues you're not really
against the main
Nexus of this particular bill but
there's other type of questions and that
sometimes happens I'm sure with many
bills in our careers up here myself 16
years I've seen this and I've seen the
government of you know a study committee
and things flounder and Float out to sea
but if we approve this and I think
you'll find our committee willing to
work with Mr Colin and with members of
the Senate if we have something the
first building block the foundation
stone is the key okay and I'm saying if
we look at this particular bill as a
foundation stone maybe as we work in the
second half of the biennium
many of the questions
can come forward so if we allow this to
go through
I don't think uh I don't know I'll let
my chair make that decision it's his
call but I'm sure there'll be people
willing on the committee
um thank you for that representative
um
I think that the impact
to the municipalities we really we
really don't have a good handle on it in
fact we had testimony that the language
was vague
and if we're going to do something we
need to be as clear as we possibly can I
don't want to put something into law and
then have to go back and fix it over and
over and over again I would rather be
proactive and try to get it as right as
we possibly can that's why we supported
the study committee
um we in the Senate we take these study
committees very seriously I can only
speak for myself
um and quite frankly I volunteered to
serve on this study committee that's
kind of like an Unwritten thing in the
Senate if you're proposing one guess who
gets to serve on it
um and so I think that we can through a
study committee strike a balance that
hopefully everybody can live with
because I agree because every time you
take a position and you go from full
time to part-time there is a loss to the
retirement system and we've we need to
figure that out but that is not a
one-size-fit-all answer and that's why
we're arguing for the study committee
and I can't believe we're arguing for a
study committee
um it's crazy I mean usually that
doesn't happen but we do agree that this
is a very important issue and it was
something that we took very seriously
and so we took a look at all the
testimony that we had we had a great
discussion in Senate Edna about this and
we've said look let's let's take a
serious look at this is this a problem
because we've heard about this
so here's an opportunity for us to
really dig in get to the bottom of this
what's happening get the language the
retirement system needs and see if we
can get a balance between the retirement
system and the municipalities where
everybody
everybody can can live with what we do
rather than put something in legislation
and then have to keep going back to fix
it so
yeah all right yep that's fine
okay
all right we did we discussed it and we
just can't agree to a study committee um
if we have to
um we're
pretty strong on this language I know
there may be some issues with what's
here from what you heard from the
retirement system
so
if
you don't want to come along to this
agenda then I'm going to end up reaching
out to the sponsor of this legislation
to have him work with the retirement
system and come back with hopefully
something that will work for all of us
next year
I think that Mr chair that's probably
the best Avenue for this issue because
we certainly respect there could be a
potential issue here we just weren't
ready to take the full step that the
house took and felt that looking at the
issue was warranted but I I think you
know we we discussed in caucus there
there may be some opportunities to do
some of this at some point but we're not
really clear on what we do would want to
do without excuse me some further
information so I think at this time we
are probably at an impasse and
we'll have to uh
try it again another year if you're
going to speak to the sponsor make sure
that the sponsor has a conversation with
the municipal Association as well as the
association of counties I think that's
extremely important to get their input
into this and to work with them to
strike a balance
and make sure they understand the impact
that it may have potentially on school
systems as well because that was one big
question that we didn't have so I think
these would all be good things to look
at going forward
appreciate it all right thank you
everyone for coming representative Brian
yeah uh Senator cossing made a great
offer and yeah thank you do you want the
prime sponsor of this to contact you to
keep you abreast in your Committee of
what we're doing and uh that that might
you know help Grease the wheel on this
one you know yeah because it sounds like
this Common Ground here I I agree with
um I really think there is some common
ground we just need to lay it out that's
all and we didn't have time to do it we
got a lot of testimony that I think is
conflicting or maybe a little more
in-depth than what the house received
and that's why it caused us to take a
step back and to start really
questioning what's going on here how do
we deal with this how do we allow the
retirement system most of all to to put
legislation in place so they can deal
with it as well so
foreign
that's fine well thank you all for your
time thank you and I'll see you at two
o'clock you will
I'll be back again are we going to be in
this room no we're over on the Senate
side on that one ah okay
all right thank you thank you Jeff thank
you and thank you for those that came
foreign
yes that's okay good afternoon we're
scoping out the issue uh yes the house
bill for that's the Senate Bill 42 yes
yes we already passed that let's just
take it out of here
everyone that's good
um
does I don't have any issues with the
changes to the actual rulemaking section
that which I understand were requests by
the by the staff
does anyone else have any concern with
them
okay
turn Ross
better better definition on the forms
[Music]
and
okay
so that's
you have our side by side yes okay good
so that's we're
all right
so we're good through page
17. we're going to delete the section on
page
18. yep
and
uh
this starting on page 19
is something that's totally new to us
and we which was
laid on the table in the Senate it's so
our position is that if you can explain
to us why we need to do it in this bill
will listen to you but we're not
otherwise inclined to accept it without
good reason so
and that's why we have Senator Whitley
because it was her legislation thank you
madam chair
um so this bill actually at the house
has seen before this is this issue has
been really worked on almost for over a
decade
um and it and it really is just laying
basement level protections for nursing
mothers in the workplace this language
was included in my bill Senate Bill 175
affectionately known as momnibus and it
was laid on the table uh as the Senate
does
a typical practice in a budget year
there was a decision made not to put it
in the budget because it was strictly
policy
um and instead to attach it to this bill
so again this was non-controversial it
has passed the Senate multiple times
um I will say that the only thing that
is different now than last year is that
the federal government has now passed
the pump act which provides Federal
protections this is a little different
because it's actually a New Hampshire
based complaint process so I wouldn't
say that there's you know new rights
that are being added but what we are
doing is making sure that New Hampshire
moms have a New Hampshire complaint
process that they don't have to go to
the EEOC that this is based in in New
Hampshire law I will say the other
issues that we are
um the folks that are working on this
were very responsive to the business
community and wanted to make sure that
it was you know it worked for our small
businesses so you'll see that the
definition for employer some states
include all employers but this includes
those employers that have six or more
employees we added of course a
definition for undue hardship
that is very important to our business
Community we also added a definition
about what a reasonable break period
actually was this was very important to
our moms
um a lot of folks who have never nursed
before don't understand that you do need
to
um pump every three hours that's a sort
of biological need of course or women
would be in a lot of pain and it's
important to maintain their supply for
their baby so that's why we defined a
reasonable break period it was also a
request that we were very specific about
that so we wanted to be responsive to
that as much as possible so
um again and then lastly there's a
hardship exemption so recognizing that
this is something that businesses need
to get used to we added that and then
lastly we pushed out the implementation
dates again while while our businesses
were getting adjusted to the federal
requirements and these new requirements
you'll see that the effective dates are
pushed out to 2025 and 2026.
I'm happy to answer any questions
representative Leon um thank you madam
chair and thank you for that explanation
I actually was unaware of the pump act I
was wondering if you could provide some
information about what the federal
protections will be
I don't have those in front of me but
there is someone here who can provide
information about the federal pump act
if the committee is interested in
hearing about that
might have as a follow-up
um thank you that's it's one of the
areas where if there is already a
protection I would want to make sure
that they're not in Conflict
um actually I can answer that I do know
I don't have the pump act but we did do
an analysis and that these are entirely
consistent with those Federal
requirements but more tailored to New
Hampshire businesses and then the all
we're not giving additional rights that
are already in federal law what we're
doing is giving a new so if a complaint
happens it will go through New Hampshire
agencies rather than federal agencies
um you mentioned a compact
compact
oh pump act excuse me
the federal legislation is called the
pump act excuse me
it does yes okay fine that makes it
makes a lot more sense thank you yes
and when is that effective
it's already effective now I'm being
told my expert is sailing right there
uh uh I will just note that Lisa soroy
is here she is uh she works with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and public health but she also um is on
the breastfeeding task force that has
worked on this legislation for decades
she's a plan
um thank you madam chair um my other
question is this only provides
protection for women up until one year
after birth of the child however the
guidelines from The Who and the CDC
recommend longer breastfeeding I'm
concerned that passing this would shut
off the opportunity for breast for
breastfeeding and expressing mothers to
have access in their workplace were we
to pass this
uh I see it as the opposite so right now
women don't have protections and and
with this they would have protections
um you know of course the the literature
supports the biological and sort of
health benefits are if women you know
nurse for a year
um we thought though that aligned with
these protections so absolutely we're
adding protections we're not taking
anyway
I have a question about it sure you say
that you have that you notify employer
two weeks prior to me needing break
periods and stuff how
all right um how is does that relate to
a temporary disability for be for having
actually having the baby
I presume that that when you come back
you you would be needing to to do this
yeah and not everyone not everyone pumps
that work I think this is for those
women who choose to pump at work
um and the request is similar to how an
employee would request a reasonable
accommodation so it's very similar to
that process
to their land
um thank you madam chair as a mom three
times I definitely appreciate the
challenges and the challenges when new
and emerging things happen with your
child one of my big concerns would be
that by placing this into our statutes a
lot of times when there's a floor of
requirements a lot of employers and
different ones come down to the floor as
opposed to what they've already offered
for their employees I have a I have a
large concern around the two-week notice
because if somebody had been working
with formula and instead they needed to
pump up they needed to increase because
their formula was no longer available
like we experienced this year and
instead they needed to increase their
pumping so that their child was fully on
pumped milk that that two-year
requirement that two-week requirement
might actually be more of a hurdle I
appreciate all the work you're trying to
do in order to codify this but I I do
know that there have been a lot of good
accommodations that have happened
through many many workplaces through the
pressure to support mothers and I think
that we've done a very good job so far
through this private negotiation between
employees and employers and I'm afraid
that this two weeks is going to hurt
moms who are going through a feeding
crisis
so thank you for that concern I think
you know we did put in here language
that nothing in this would prohibit
employees and employers from negotiating
what works best for them
um I think we there are some businesses
that do this great but I know Lisa can
specifically you know has received
complaints from moms where some business
artists aren't doing so this is a
basement level floor of protections for
moms super important because we know
that a lot of moms leave the workforce
right in the first year we just know
that in particular during the pandemic
we lost 10 percent of our Workforce
between ages 25 and 34. these are our
new moms they just left the workforce
and unfortunately they're not coming
back this is not a Panacea to solve that
problem but it's a piece of the puzzle a
lot of moms leave leave the workforce
because they just cannot manage both
things I know that it was a challenge
for me and I I had a a very supportive
uh workplace I was able to pump at work
and it kept in the workforce frankly
representative
thank you madam chair on page 20 the
last paragraph number three
it says that a nursing employee shall
notify its employer at least two weeks
prior to needing reasonable break
periods and sufficient space for
expression of milk I would I think that
it should say to protect the employer
how that notice is to be given
um being a Massachusetts employer we've
hit this several several times where if
it's not specific enough an employee may
say oh I notified you and it was out of
text or it was an email or it didn't go
to the right email or the email was
rejected so I think it needs to be per
employer's
policies thank you
yeah that's a great suggestion we could
either say shell notify in writing or
she'll notify in line
as with the employer's policies I would
be happy to include any of those
I think in line with the employer's
policies would be the appropriate thing
wouldn't you agree
employers policies thank you for that
suggestion
thank you
okay
so yeah I'm concerned about this um not
so much the break period but the
sufficient space bit depending on
what the facilities are
that may be incredibly difficult to to
accomplish I mean I I worked in the
storefront um
the drugstore
and there wasn't any place where you
could have privacy outside of the site
of people
except the bathroom which you've
explicitly eliminated
so I think that that's a
is something that is
a major problem for some very small
employers and I would think that you
would want to
increase the number of employees that
this of the size of the businesses this
would applied to thank you for that
there was a lot of conversation about
about just that issue I will note that
this they're already required in federal
law to do this again the sufficient
space we chose this sixth number because
um
uh our New Hampshire non-discrimination
statute applies to businesses with six
or more employees so the Department of
Labor actually provided us some legal
advice that this was the best
um definition of employer that aligned
with current law so that's why we chose
that number
and the sufficient space you know again
we're not requiring them or federal law
doesn't require them nor does this law
require the building of a new pod or the
creation it's just um uh you know just
this area and there's definition of what
that area should be and of course that
it's important that it's not a bathroom
although I know many many moms have
probably pumped or nursed in a bathroom
um but again that we wanted to make this
as consistent with existing federal laws
possible and likewise with who it should
apply to that was consistent with New
Hampshire law as well
thank you so one of the concerns that I
have when we write our own law because
we want to include the federal law is if
the changes if there are changes to the
federal law I mean
does the federal law apply to people to
businesses in New Hampshire now
I would love to defer to Lisa if she can
talk about the federal law it's just not
my area of expertise if the committee
would oblige I'm asking that question
follow up because if we write a separate
law and then something changes in the
federal law do we are we therefore then
creating a situation where we have to
change you know what I mean I see what
you're saying so this doesn't necess
this is still going to be New Hampshire
statute so say the federal law goes away
this will stand on its own
more more importantly what happens if
there's a major change to the federal
law this will stand on its own so this
doesn't refer to federal law this stands
on its own so we would have to we you
know they would have to they could
repeal the pump act and this would
remain
because okay follow up thank you so I'm
looking at this sufficient space thing
and I know from from my from my own
committee
language like the location of the space
provides shall be within a reasonable
walk of the employee's work site well
what does that mean what is a reasonable
walk
it's those kinds of yes no and I
appreciate all these questions and I
will say that you know there you know
these were all um extensive
conversations that we had with the
business community and with the
stakeholders
um uh and we didn't want to say it has
to be within a mile we didn't say it had
to be in a half a mile so um a
reasonable walk needs to stand stand on
its own unless we want to define the the
mile or you know but I don't think we
want to do that either I think again
this is a conversation between employee
and an employer and we want to maintain
that flexibility yeah
representative Leon um thank you my
question had actually been similar to
that I I can't imagine being able to
walk a mile one way pump and then walk a
mile the other way certainly that only
30 minutes yeah that wouldn't be
reasonable my other question would be do
you consider it reasonable for those who
are in the state house to walk all the
way to the lob basement for the nursing
pod or would you do you think that it's
more reasonable that you don't have to
walk from building to building again we
didn't want to be that prescriptive and
so you know if the employee doesn't
think it's reasonable they have an
opportunity to work on that but again we
wanted to maintain that flexibility and
not Define that what is determined to be
reasonable and this is you know a
similar legal standard that's in most of
our laws
then as a follow-up if an employee says
that it's not reasonable to walk during
session from the state house over to the
nursing pod in the basement of the lob
who would they take that up with if they
believe that that's taking in their way
away from their duties either here or at
another facility so this statute is
within the Department of Labor so the
federal law the complaint is to the you
know Federal EOC so complaints pursuant
to the statute would be with our New
Hampshire Department of Labor and
they're and they advise heavily on the
drafting of this
well
since you've carefully made this section
not into effect until 2025
I don't see why we need to include it in
in this bill
because women have waited for decades
for these protections we really have
worked for decades on this language
um and I just you know the this issue
got a lot of press for a long time and I
think it's time that New Hampshire you
know enacts these state level
protections to get our women back to
work okay
um one my concern is that you know fine
you want to make a statement but you're
not actually going to do anything for
another year so there's no reason we
can't this could come in legislation
next year so you say there's been
conversations but they've been in the
Senate
the house has not been involved uh this
exact version of the bill was heard by
the house last year and it was also
discussed a different in conference
right yeah absolutely absolutely
um the the the time the effective date
was to get businesses to get to have for
them to have time so representative
that's what we've wanted to do
I have a logistics question I guess
Madam chair thank you
um
if we have federal law already in place
to to govern this for mothers what is
the purpose of this at a state level
please thank you yeah thank you for that
question so it's twofold one instead of
having to complain to the federal
government administrative agency this
allows moms and employers employees to
go through a state level process to the
Department of Labor and that's really
important for folks to have a local
complaint process
um the second is that it was important
to all stakeholders to have a new
hampshire-based solution to have New
Hampshire law that worked for us and so
that's why this language was so narrowly
tailored to our New Hampshire businesses
thank you madam chair for the follow-up
um Senator my my question ranges around
the confusion that's created for an
employer with the Department of Labor in
Massachusetts for example we have
Department of Labor Federal level we
have Department of Labor state level and
it creates more confusion for every new
thing added that oh this complies over
here this doesn't comply over here we
can get in trouble from this agency can
get in trouble from this agency too so
um it just I think it adds another layer
of confusion for employers as well when
the employees already protected
right and I and I think the the issue is
that
um you know we have there's Federal
non-discrimination and then there's also
State non-discrimination and and that
goes to the Human Rights Commission in
New Hampshire and so you know it's just
a reality in in a democracy you know
like like the United States we're going
to have state and federal law that folks
have to deal with and I think we have to
balance here the rights of moms the
rights of babies with the rights of
employers and I think this strikes that
balance
uh thank you madam chair
um was there a fiscal note for what it
would cost for our department of labor
to address your expected violations of
the statute no there wasn't
as a follow-up do you think that there
would be a significant involvement here
at the state level Department of Labor
or do you think most of that would go to
the federal level
complaints through this statute will go
to the Department of Labor and they were
intimately involved with drafting the
statute and didn't raise concerns about
uh enforcement
sorry it's my last follow-up do you
think that the reason there was no
fiscal note is because this would go
into effect in the next budget as
opposed to going into effect now uh no
there wasn't a fiscal note when this
identical language was introduced in
previous sessions and also when it was
introduced before this effective date
was changed
I'm sorry I'm just trying to grasp
around the need for this and then not
having a fiscal use fiscal note because
there's not an expectation that it would
be used much at the state level in order
to oh no I think there's no fiscal note
because the Department of Labor already
has the capacity to enforce it
should we caucus for a moment
okay we'll caucus for a few minutes
foreign
thank you for waiting thank you
um we were just consolidating our
concerns and we would like to say that
this should not be a part of this bill
this year because
we think it is not
thoroughly worked out for employers that
are not inclined to be protective of
their employees they're going to
complain about what's reasonable
what's reasonable what's sufficient
and things like that and we think that
if you're going to address that you need
a little more specificity in some areas
we're also concerned that it has not
been approved by the house
and we would like to work on it
and with a 2025 effective date we can do
that
uh next spring
so we're you would also like to take the
opportunity to see what the Federal
Regulations are how the Federal Federal
Regulations are implemented and what the
problems with them are because that's
where we really want to address the
state regulations
yeah I will just say that you know the
business Bia was involved in this and
they had all the input and they you know
didn't uh make those suggestions that
you're suggesting I mean as I said this
has been worked on for decades with a
lot of input so this but this is past
ready for prime time
so thank you so Senator if I'm not
mistaken the um part of the reason of
putting the 2025 date was to give
businesses plenty of notification I
think that offers the house a unique
opportunity here that if we leave this
bill language in it gives you the
opportunity to put a bill in next year
you could put even the same language
work on it and make changes that you
could have an effect
with the same enactment date or one
prior whichever way it would have to be
to to overrule what's you know what I
mean to make the changes that you might
have objections to here but on the same
token we're giving the businesses
notification that something is coming
and that they need to be ready and able
to handle it so that would be my
suggestion is that we leave the language
here and it gives you a full year of
opportunity to introduce a bill in
September if you want to and again you
can introduce the same exact Bill and
put it through the whole process and
work on it
representative Leon
um thank you madam chair I appreciate
the idea of having that Clarity and
transparency of having the law in a fact
a year but having the law go into effect
a year after it's passed and I
appreciate that idea of working through
but if there's a bill in process in the
house and they don't know until until we
reach this this point next year what the
actual law will be I think that that
might actually bring more confusion to
the employers as opposed to less
confusion so I appreciate that that idea
but I think it might actually create
more confusion
Senator thank you madam chair
um representative I completely disagree
um one of the the two words that I've
heard
um throughout this is reasonable and and
what is sufficient and if we don't have
something in here for the State of New
Hampshire
if any if a business has a question
um or they have a concern about anything
they now have to address it federally
they're not going to have a state
pathway and it's going to make it much
harder and I think it's going to end up
being more confusing so that's why I
support this amendment being placed on
this bill I agree with my colleague from
the Senate this is not anything new
We have dealt with this issue before and
I agree that it is time that we do this
we want to get women back into the
workforce and this is an impediment for
them I'm glad the federal government has
finally seen how important this is and
we do have someone here who can walk us
through the federal act if Madam chair
would allow her to come forward so that
we would have a better idea about what
it's looking what it looks like
but um as it stands now I support this
provision on this bill
representative
you had a comment
nope sorry
I'm not so your suggestion that we added
to this we keep it in here and that we
go through the process next year of
are you saying that any changes in a
bill that we would submit would then be
overridden
and it would override this yes certainly
yes
so this
I understand the idea of it and I and I
first of all I
support the concept of the bill
of the amendment
I think it's everything that Senator
Whitley said I
agree with
but I'm hesitant to put something into
law
and then it gets changed I mean we do
this often you know we do something then
we go oops we should have done it this
way or oops we should have done done it
that way
and that is something that we deal with
in our committee all the time
specifically in Edna so
I'm trying I try after my first term I
thought I'm gonna not gonna be a partner
in this
in this crime of
of legislation
um
so why is it that
it seems strange to me that the Senate
didn't put it in the budget and I don't
this idea about the policy is fine but
we put policy in House Bill too many
times
thank you thank you so much there was a
lot of debate about that but my
understanding is that leadership in both
the house and the senate for the
purposes of passing a budget last budget
cycle there was a lot of unnecessary
policy and so there was
a lot of effort to make this a
bipartisan budget that didn't have
policy in it you know we could have
easily slipped this into the budget but
with respect to House and Senate
leadership we did not
so
what that implies to me is that this
policy is not firmly supported by House
and Senate leadership or they would have
put it in the budget
and I'm also concerned with putting
this in so far in advance I think that
we
I would be much more
um
I would be much better
pleased if this said that if you went in
with the policies all right each
employer shall adopt a policy yes yeah
we they should and make it available to
the employees
and then come back and work out the
details because I think the details are
not thoroughly worked out and if it's
been worked for decades without coming
to a conclusion that means there is not
solid agreement on what the policy
should be so if I might respond yes so
with regards to the budget we were asked
as chairs to try and not put any policy
into the budget if at all possible and
and this bill has passed the house twice
with 24-0 Excuse me the Senate twice
with the 24-0 four times four times I
knew it and but I mean in this session
this session correct twice we passed it
we passed it as part of a greater bill
with uh Senate bill 175.
and we took many of those pieces that
had Financial components and put them in
the budget and the remaining pieces that
because we tabled the bill so that we
could do that and the remaining policy
pieces we put on to other bills just
because we felt they were important but
we didn't want to stick them in House
Bill too we were trying to avoid that
Christmas tree ornament as much as
possible and do it in a different manner
so so the Senate is very committed to
this position and has passed it twice
24-0
thank you madam Sharon thank you for
that prospective Senator
um I appreciate the challenge with
Christmas trees but I feel like now
we're putting on ornaments on every
wreath on every door if we're putting
these policy sections on other bills my
biggest concern Remains The
implementation of the federal law and if
we can pause and look and see what
happens and see if we can address those
differences and those deficiencies in
federal law in a way that's very New
Hampshire specific as they go as players
go through and adopt these policies
which they'll need to in order to be in
compliance and we can figure out figure
out where we can better serve our people
and and Nuance the federal law to serve
Granite State moms I think that
I think that it's important to take the
time to do it in a way that also has the
buy-in of the Full House as opposed to
coming through a committee of conference
because while this is passed the Senate
many times it has not yet passed the
house for various reasons in various
years
yes and would
would it be acceptable to say that
immediately we should pass on page 20 of
the okay there's there's policies
every employer shall adopt a policy
every employer shall make this available
to their employees
that's the thing that they need to know
right now that we're going to be doing
it not the
they need to know that a year in advance
not
um
clean space sheltered sheltered from you
I mean it's there's a lot of
questions about the resting
representative they may so I
our businesses told us as we worked on
this that they don't know what a
reasonable break period is they don't
know what a sufficient space is so if we
just say pass apology do this without
any structure I think that would provide
so much more confusion to our employers
also we are wanna we are the only state
in New England that does not have state
level protections so I will say
employers are very used to this language
and I think New Hampshire is making a
very strong statement if we don't pass
this bill
yeah
yes
sir
foreign
all right thank you for giving us to
break
we've
agreed that since there is time to
correct the technical deficiencies in
this bill that we will agree to include
it in house bill 358. if that's okay
thank you very much thank you okay so
I will prepare an amendment deleting
Senate bill 42.
since we don't need that anymore
all right everyone everyone in agreement
Madam chair do you want to make the
change suggested by representative on
page 20.
oh yes that's right we're uh yes
so it could read on the last line a
nursing employee shall notify
in writing yeah or we could in line with
the employer's policy yeah I think that
was the language but then maybe we put
that Clause after let me say I'm
notified some player
at least two weeks maybe we should put
the closet back up with something that
adds adds that you know that the
notification is in the proper style to
be
great to be thank you very much thank
you okay awesome thank you thank you all
thank you
and we have a few minutes before the
next one
thank you Kim I appreciate your uh
okay thank you all
we're uh
resuming on House Bill 409 as after the
um
representative Broder remembered
something else we need to look at on
this bill so if you'd bring it if you
could help us figure out where it goes
right there is
um
a what we'd like to do is on the bottom
of page 10 line 37 6 and 37 which of
course I don't have that bill in front
of me we wanted to um include a sentence
what would you read the title because
we're we don't have pages on ours on the
on the side by side oh okay let me let
me try to find it I'm so sorry that's
okay
oops
it has to do with um experts qualified
experts so let me see if I can that's
the part I'm looking for it's what it
has to do with qualified experts right
oh I'm on the wrong
I'm on 358 let me go to 409.
it would help
ah okay
did you find it on the uh it's on uh
yeah it's in the middle somewhere
[Laughter]
is it the section that says the office
shell employee sufficient correct
Personnel qualified by reason of
Education competence and relative
experience yes what section is that in
it's Roman four
and it's in 310 10 Roman 4.
it's about the middle of the package
at the top of the page yes okay so
what's the concern with that one I
wanted to see so the sentence I wanted
to read to modify the sentence to read
retain qualified experts appointed by
the executive director in accordance
with criteria established by the board
ah
um oh this is this is not for
prosecutors this is for investigators
yes all right then then I gave you the
wrong citation it's probably before that
okay let me see if I can
just recuseum
is it under complaints and
investigations which should be under
complaints and investigations
so that is three ten nine no it's not
three it's three ten it's three ten nine
that's right
and the
three ten nine
[Music]
okay
well there's three ten nine and then
there's there's room oh investigations
yes okay
retain qualified experts that have
sufficient knowledge on a statute to
professions and their practices
is that um yes instead of that ah okay
so we have retained qualified experts
appointed by the executive director in
accordance with criteria established by
the board
so
ah okay yeah
what we're doing in this section is we
are giving
the oplc staff Authority and so it says
to carry out investigations the
executive director is authorized to
retain qualified experts right and so I
just don't know if we need appointed by
the executive director I think it's more
that yeah it should say according to
criteria established by the board is it
well we're giving her the authority to
to a point right right
so this language came from oplc
and
so that's where I mean that's where the
language came from her concerns that had
been brought up okay so instead of just
saying that have sufficient knowledge on
statutes or professions should say
according to criteria established by the
board yes okay
and just to clarify if I may so part of
what we discussed in committee was sort
of like the division between staff and
board
and I think I've discussed this with
representative and I think I think we're
on the same page which is that
you know the board really sort of
retains substantive duties with the
executive director kind of retains
procedural ones but it was important
that they have sort of independent
authority to hire investigators so I
just want to make sure we've sort of
fully thoughts I I think the point of
this is that the boards say we need to
have
I don't know a child psychologist
familiar with this the this area and
then the board then the director hires
one
it doesn't the board doesn't approve who
the executive director is hiring it's
just that they're setting the criteria
for what those expert witness experts
would be responsible for like I'd say
it's somebody who has
um
somebody that's involved let's say it's
a medical issue and it's a thoracic
issue right then it would be somebody
who's involved with whatever that part
of
medicine medicine is those would be
experts that have expertise in those
areas and the executive director may not
necessarily know that for every
profession yeah and also that gives the
once you have the criteria
it's easier for for the office to pick
somebody that won't create as much of a
conflict of interest as if the board did
it yeah if I may I as I recall on this
and I may have to rely on Mr osaw a
little bit because he filled Us in on
this uh if my memory serves me correctly
we were trying to draw a clear
distinction between the investigator and
the adjudicator right and by allowing
the board to do that in essence it'd be
like giving the agility the ability to
decide and have some input on who the
expert Witnesses were that were coming
in and I think that was an area of
concern that we were trying to stay away
from well that's why the language says
according to criteria established by the
board because the board knows what
criteria are important
and this is for the investigator it
wouldn't be unfair to the person being
investigated that the board is deciding
what expert Witnesses they'd like to no
it's not what expert what is the time
the criteria expert Witnesses you'd have
to offer that same thing that same
ability to the person being investigated
because that's the whole point of having
in my opinion of having the investigator
and the jury in essence they're two
separate things yeah well this is the
investigator and the board says we need
someone familiar with this profession
and this whatever else they establish
and they
the office says okay go we'll go find
somebody that meets those criteria would
it be okay if we asked Mr O's to help
for an opinion on it all right we will
ask our uh the the attorney for the oplc
to clarify that exactly
because I I think it it is a good idea
to have the board establish what type of
experts are needed in a particular case
I think it's our understanding that
like you were saying representative grow
to that if the board sets those criteria
that we wouldn't necessarily have to go
to the board for approval of that
individual but we would look at those
criteria and say this is what the expert
we hire these are the criteria they need
to meet but we could still act
procedurally independently of the board
as long as that individual met those
criteria you'd be okay with that change
I am okay with that change John and I
were just talking I do have one concern
that there might what happens if the
board hasn't set criteria
uh he's of the opinion that if there's
no criteria oplc could just go
I would think that's the case okay and
we could clarify that right if the board
is not set right here yet then sure if
none then then the opalc decides okay
yeah I mean we almost could solve it
with an or I mean if it says routine
qualified experts according to criteria
established by the board or oh that's
fine yeah that works too but even better
that's fine
or very good
I think
or all right so
to continue we have
um
a second advanced practice registered
nurse on the board of of nursing delete
the specific Nursing education member
um
changing 310.5 to match the Senate Bill
49 language right so we're changing the
five billion to three million yeah and
make sure all the other language is
there we're going to make this change
on the investigators
and like anything else
okay I think that's the effective date
yes
um to 7 15 is that 7 15 yeah two changes
about the Board of Nursing right yep
I think that leaves was only one point
of contention right that's section 27
the compact that we're still opposed to
the Senate feels very strongly that this
language is good and that this compact
needs to be in place
we do respect that the house has a
different opinion
we understand that you're working on it
and you have a bill retained
it's that doesn't give us necessarily
the Assurance we were hoping to get that
we could get something through because
my feeling is you're going to have the
same problems in September when you're
working on retain bills that you have in
June because there won't be any rules
established by September either
so I did I'm concerned that
it puts all of this language at Jeopardy
in this whole Social Work compact in
jeopardy
in the interim I have spoken with oplc
about the potential of getting social
workers
uh the reciprocity that we passed under
594. that will impact them potentially
some so I guess we are taking a little
bit of ease with knowing that we're
going to help the situation as it
currently exists
we aren't again we aren't happy about
removing this language
in the least we felt very strongly that
it needed to be there and voted very
unanimously in the Senate to have it
but we also feel that the remainder of
the language in 409 is critically
important as we move forward and
Implement 655 and
594.
so with
some hesitation and a bit of unhappiness
we will
agree to remove this part to save the
rest of the bill but I will say that
we're going to very much be looking to
you and encouraging you to look at this
language in the retained bill that you
have and make sure something good
happens with it this fall yes
so with that we will agree
regretfully to the change of taking this
up
Madam chair your microphones off just
well that makes it harder for you to
hear me doesn't it
okay so uh thank you Senator I will
prepare an amendment that makes the
minor changes we've discussed and delete
the
um
um the section 27 and that should be it
and mostly effective date out to July
15th at as we believe we're good with it
yeah I think that addresses all the
changes yes
okay thank you for working with us
and good luck in the rest of your
Committee of conferences
I have five done now I've only got one
left uh all right thank you thanks
everyone